seeing as the guy has been referred to
as the real life iron man i think
practically no one would be surprised to
know that elon musk likes to live like
the billionaire he is with that being
said though once you really get deep
into the guy's multi-million dollar
collection you can't help but be amazed
at just how incredible his collection
can be and so if you're interested in
finding out more buckle up because in
this video we're going to explore
everything from good old ford model ts
to cars of the future in elon musk's car
collection like all car collections that
grow to be significant there has to be
one original car that started it all and
like jay leno and other enthusiasts
before him elon start was shockingly
humble especially when compared to today
in the form of a 1978 bmw 320i a pretty
standard used car elon bought it as a
regular transport as soon as he had
moved to the states for the meager sum
of fourteen hundred dollars far from the
mind-bending cars that he would later
develop the 320i was still a pretty
advanced car for its time and more
importantly it also showed for the first
time the way the guy was headed seeing
as in a later interview musk said that
he was in fact the guy who fixed up the
car did that have any correlation with
him becoming chief engineer of one of
the world's most incredible projects
i'll leave that question up to you guys
moving on we must now give you some bad
news because as it turns out the 320i
did not last super long and after having
owned it for two years musk had to say
goodbye to the car when an intern at his
company drove the car into an accident
but the bad times did not last long
because soon afterwards musk got one of
his first proper self-indulgent moments
when he received the bonus for the
company he had founded called zip2 by
buying a jaguar e-type now when musk got
the 40 000 bonus instead of investing it
into something new like you would
usually do seeing as he had just become
carlos musk decided to treat himself to
a childhood dream see as musk would
later reveal when he was 17 he was
looking through a classic car book as 17
year olds are often known to do and like
anyone else who's flipped through those
pages he told himself that if he could
ever afford it he would buy one and
that's where the relatable part ends
because unlike you and me who's dreamt
of a classic 60s jaguar musk actually
managed to buy one and drive it for
quite a while now a word to the wise
those cars however cool they may look
are not known for being the most
convenient to drive and sure that's good
for a car collection but driving it
daily was another affair one elon would
describe as like a bad girlfriend it
kept breaking down on me and causing me
all sorts of trouble and so when a few
years later he sold paypal for a
historic 1.5 billion dollars elon
decided he needed another addition to
the collection which turned out to be
none other than a mclaren f1 now if
you're not a car geek like me the
mclaren f1 is the car that iron man
would have dreamed of if the movie came
out in the 90s from being one of the
most exclusive pieces of automotive
history to being the fastest car on the
road for the longest period of any
modern car the list of praises goes on
and on all of which made it the perfect
car for elon musk that is until he
crashed it that's right during an
interview about the car elon recalled
the experience i had it for several
years and i put 11 000 miles on it and i
drove it from la to san francisco and i
had it as a daily driver and also
recalled the time when he was driving
with paypal co-founder peter thiel when
the following happened peter said so
what can this do and like probably
number one on the list of famous last
words i said watch this so i floored it
and did a lane change on sand hill and
almost immediately the car swerved out
of control hit an embankment and
actually flew in the air like a discus
before crashing the next car added to
his collection was another jaw dropper
and one that somehow suited him even
more than the f1 or e-type that's right
we're talking about the famous james
bond lotus esprit that's right in 2013
elon musk became the proud owner of the
exact car that had tormented the
imagination of kids for generations ever
since they saw james bond drive the
thing underwater in the spy who loved me
[Music]
talking of the experience he once told
the huffington post it was amazing as a
little kid in south africa to watch
james bond and the spy who loved me
drive his lotus esprit off a pier press
a button and have it transform into a
submarine underwater i was disappointed
to learn that it can't actually
transform what i'm gonna do is upgrade
it with a tesla electric powertrain and
try to make it transform for real now
while to the ears of elon that might
sound like a deal breaker you must also
understand the fact that the guy bought
the car on auction for a whopping 920
thousand dollars there's my favorite
playboy now moving on to some slightly
less interesting cars first we have the
audi q7 which as it turns out directly
led to the famous falcon wing doors in
the tesla model s this was a result of
the horrible way the third row accessed
by climbing over the middle row or as he
put it in the best case scenario you
need to be a dwarf mountain climber to
get into the back seat one car which was
surely not a disappointment however is a
hammond bmw
m5 driven by elon for a small period of
time in 2007 this baby is to a standard
bmw what a bmw is to a corolla and goes
to show just how important it is to elon
to have a fast car and while it can't
compete with the sheer brutal speed of
his modern cars with a monstrous 603
horsepower 5-liter v10 i doubt the thing
felt slow and as it turns out that's not
the only time that elon has been seen
driving good old-fashioned horsepowers
because he's also said to have owned a
few porsche 911s in fact in the case of
the 911 musk has actually admitted just
how much he enjoys driving the german
car quoting it as one of his absolute
favorites to drive and that finally
brings us back to the last unusual car
on the list a pristine 1920 ford model t
in 2007 elon surprised many fans by
saying that he had just become the proud
owner of one of the most influential
cars of all time
that being said to people who know elon
well that was hardly a surprise seeing
just how big a fan elon was of the old
car and in a very poetic way this card
joins into the next heading of our list
because just as the model t kick-started
the automobile revolution elon musk and
his teslas have become responsible for
the biggest car revolution since teslas
we all knew this was coming but we must
include this portion because let's face
it ever since tesla has started to make
actually good machines there's no set of
cars which elon has driven more than his
own from being one of the few owners of
the original tesla roadster which stood
proudly in his garage until it was
actually launched into space in 2018 to
having driven numerous model s and model
x editions over the years there's no
shortage of the t logo in elon's life
however that doesn't mean he doesn't
like exclusively because as we started
to learn tesla might have a knack for
exciting cars too in the form of tesla
cyber truck which as it turns out elon
was seen driving in malibu during
december of 2019
[Applause]
so i think it's fair to say that whether
he's driving a car from history taking
the fast lane in the legends of yore or
driving his own stuff elon's car
collection is one not to be messed
around with and on that note we must end
today's video i hope you enjoyed
watching it and if you did be sure to
leave a like and subscribe for more with
that take care and i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
you